hello welcome to this video I'm playing
a stair from the you came and I'm going
for a 44 change some variety in orem
okay I'm playing the turusch mostly
because as a non è for specialists I
feel like this is probably a good idea
doing something a little bit less
demanding and then known 93 and cam
starting with this see you five now yeah
now White has a choice can go for Bishop
d3 or f4 f4 is an interesting line quite
ambitious i really i think that Bishop
d3 is probably bad habit it was
interesting let's do this what is aiming
for that white center the right word
white center broad center yeah it's
important to put the denied on f3 so
that we get some kind of development
going hmm okay it's an early capture I
think that's early like like normally
doesn't do that so quickly to be a
little bit more flexible there might be
rare occasions where you can go see for
it is really a rare occasion but made
feels like it helps me a little bit that
I already know that it's the capture
already happened let's say yeah it
should be Sam
so that is a slower approach okay I'm
just going to develop this is sometimes
not possible to just play Bishop d3 okay
wants to set up a full block there okay
I don't want to capture I think this is
not a great IDM so I'm just developing
further if I caption night x this f4
move doesn't make much sense there a Z
far as we can dent it limits my bouche
event I just rather want to play this
position where I would always be a
little bit more comfortable okay let's
make mistakes here but why should have
said something because of the f40 54
this chain is just more active than d 5
is 6 + f5 it's just a matter of having a
little bit more space however blacks
position is not like terribly bad it's
just a bit um it's a bit passive yeah so
anything drastic sometimes white can now
play with the very quicker because you
won energy form I don't know what that
is a serious option in in this position
now I got rather castle if I want to
play with g4 I can still go King edge
one root g one g form this is a key idea
pushing g for gaining even more space
yeah what is flex plan now often they go
Knight b6 Bishop d7 this kind of setup
yeah this type of position is sometimes
a little bit a little bit older
estimated by by white he's certainly
somewhat better but it's not that big a
deal black is very very solid it's just
not not the kind of position that yeah
makes you you know jump up and down with
joy it's kind of its kind of stodgy so
what happens night before is probably an
option I cannot give up that Bishop so
something like Bishop e3 night before we
should be one night c4 looks a bit
awkward if I go III has 85 and possibly
a 4 to install a piece on c4 this is
something to take into account a 3 a 5
p-3 a 4b for this kind of thing black
get some night to see form
I'm preparing this G for business and on
night before Bishop you won at least a
further a three kicks the night back
it's not really clear that this helps of
a lot I could have played h3 maybe a
tree on g4 and King h2 maybe not a big
deal I I guess black also casts on a
good move like Bishop d7 now that also
allows possible Bishop e82 g6 in case
our chief for this is why I shreeji for
maybe yours bad I just a little bit bit
quicker hmm
okay let me prepare this we should be
aight i will go age three and go from
them I don't know maybe he just allows
g4 you never know okay his ideas not its
maybe maybe we can only guess it's maybe
Bishop to g5 to be 5 i'm sorry maybe
this is an idea i don't think that this
is particularly great the bishop I think
shut down should go over to the Queen
side to help in the defense but okay
well night before in itself is not a
problem for him they can do that but
if he goes Bishop b5 now that that that
is wrong I believe that's the wrong IDM
that is also the bishop on b5 is just on
an empty diagonal I don't really believe
that this helps much you can certainly
go rook c8 or something but then g-form
I might just play that something like g4
takes ruchi for this can become a very
serious attack within a very in very
short order okay so he does he somehow
reacts to the whole business there but
not with exactly what I believe would
happen so okay let's say g4 he basically
has to take it otherwise I don't really
see any sense in this I wonder ever
should play a three first
so that jump after knight c6 which looks
pretty forced I have a possible queen d
3 okay but g4 is very logical now g4
takes rook takes Queen to h5 yeah the
rook is hanging unfortunately don't
really have a great move them in Quincy
one maybe Quincy one is interesting
threatening on g7 and but still I don't
really see how to get rid of his Queen
there I mean it looks better for wild
but still
maybe I don't know h3 is an interesting
move still dizzy for ticks maybe after
g4 takes I have something better I think
I'm going to kick that night back so
that I have queen bee three this is
really a very useful option to have yeah
he will go back to c 6 9 a-6 looks
really strange ok so now g form if you
take syd i was thinking queen d3y a g6
rupee for looks fantastic and queen bee
three Queen h 593 that might hold it
doesn't look particularly great but
maybe it hurts
hmm so g4 takes group TX queen age five
queen bee three then doesn't really do
much
yeah it's still probably that [ __ ] g1
move Queen g1 rook f7 it's still kind of
solid I don't have 93 maybe f5 but
that's a very brutal approach now
probably not g4 takes kundi three again
let's check it Queen age five I don't
see a great move there amazingly enough
nigeria maybe even clean a tree looks
playable as weird as it looks okay it's
not that's not working mmm okay well
it's not like he's threatening much I
probably have some time
come on I'm going to prepare the whole
bus business heavens with age three the
idea is not not to take with the porn
after G for FTX even though that would
be that's interesting actually it's very
interesting actually my idea was to play
G for takes root chicks and then after
greenedge 5m through King age to then 93
that was my initial idea but G for F
takes G 4-h takes g4 is rather strong
the idea is just kimchi to hook h1 and
black is completely killed an idea that
I should keep in mind is b3 by the way
that keeps the night on c4 and away from
C for that jump is prevented and as
sometimes have rigged a true yeah this
is a move that i actually had expected
and i was thinking king edge to should
be good for g4 takes rook takes and then
93 I just wonder ever have something
better I mean I can go now g3 here but
he has Queen g6 ok so I'm going with
this and prefer sorry prepare g4 takes
rook takes as I had said earlier instead
of King edge 183 King age 2 and so on
was an option and maybe it yeah maybe
that was a better option even ultimately
I believe that
the queen is not that well placed on g
606 on age five kind of i was just
thinking that he could try there should
be a to g six and some positions but the
queen is really really off on age five
it is not well coordinated yeah one one
one thing was this be three rookie two
and then switch over to g to wear that's
something to keep in mind so that
actually and all of my pieces play a
role with this bishop on c1 and on b1
the rukon a one looks kind of sad and i
have to take that into account okay but
oops no way g4 and that was the idea and
down it's really no reason not to play
it i think
something like be three UK to Nigeria
Butchie to something like that would be
great yeah I can second and do that
pre-move pre moving is cool but in 25
minutes yes I still don't have on an
established rating in 25 i believe i
still like some some games i've played
quite a bit but it's not enough
currently with my rating i would be
number two on the list yet i have played
a couple of people who are in that in
that list it's no one there's just one
feeder master on it but not not many
title players besides that
and so what exactly is he doing I'm am i
threatening something that's important
to establish when every move maybe maybe
93 23 that is close to being a threat
yeah Bishop e82 g6 but it's not it's not
really a good situation for that Wow
well what about your queen buddy 93
queen age 6 f5 that looks terrible no
come on there is really it's really
nothing right there is no tactic or what
does whatever nothing there nothing
special yeah queen age 6 the only move
and then f5 and the Queen has no squares
I mean no squares yeah i was thinking
like a known i take c 5 or any business
on the c1 bishop but that's nothing
working nothing works that just lost
yeah the sudden end to that game
basically black resigns yeah he resigned
there is really am no hope here queen
age 6 this f5 and the queen is trapped
yeah it really has absolutely no where
to go if he takes here actually i will
probably play be sure that five it seems
a bit better even than this it still is
a little little bit a little bit
complicated in this kind of thing
nope push it by five is really stronger
the Queen remains trapped here and now
i'm taking takes takes into this and
this is very very nice now I've got the
Queen for rogue and Bishop and an
overwhelming attack okay if we review
the whole thing yeah that line black now
took as I said I think this is a bit
early but it's not a huge mistake
anything it just doesn't feel completely
precise black I think normally goes
queen bee six in this position after
which shone why chooses between h3g 3 h
4 and 92 i play a three here and
somewhat forgotten line but interesting
that ideas to play even before i take
control over the be four square said no
and there's no check them well okay he
took there should be seven yeah now i
can actually develop that vision this is
something if black goes with this then i
cannot easily develop as d 4 is just
hanging this is important this night is
blocking this check on b5 so it can
really just take that pawn so this this
was already i think a slight slightly
inaccurate way of playing even though
blankets of course not in a terrible
shape it is still very solid and castles
castles Knight b6 that is fine i believe
King h1 yet here you can think of
different things this is also
interesting going for this somewhat a
similar maneuver that could be better
also G form is interesting immediately
without any prep if you imagine let's
say this and I go G form the thing is
that
after kingi to Luke edge one fields
feels wrong for black and yeah probably
he goes g6 and then I know I'm taking
walking edge to or something Mary King
edge to interesting position it's kind
of related to the one that we had but
Luke g1 you're really going for this
yeah now this I don't believe in this
very much I was thinking that this is a
good idea to try to play I mean everyone
play G for now I would play age 38 here
in this pollution but here this is the
idea Bishop to g6 if I go G for this
Bishop g6 and this fields ok I mean if
he can trade those pieces it definitely
is ok after this I probably would have
gone h3 and gap it remains an
interesting complicated position and
yeah night before and now Queenie ate
that feels wrong this is also not a
great idea this is kind of off side yam
there's nothing to attack and something
like hearing there's this and then g4
seems good for white gathered Bishop is
just not on the right diagonal they are
queenly eight hmm and I don't really
believe in this very much a three back
and age three preparing this this G
phone booth yeah and now we really
played played this I don't know
yeah more normal is this kind of think
the ideas a 495 probably I go be three
now or g4 I'm not question but some yeah
well this was played and I prepare to
form and Roxy eight and four and take
stakes yeah and now and this is this is
just losing he has to do something else
I liked my position but it's probably
not yet that grade not that great yet
would be probably the better way to
arrange that sentence yeah what is it
doing now a group sees seven or
something from some flexible move I know
let's play one I just want one too once
you get a fear what would happen fever
what happens um yeah 93 is interesting
but not clear ever need this this is
also a good move here intending this
this is lift as we said yeah the thing
is i don't know i mean does he really
have this opportunity or something like
this that leads nowhere then maybe even
95 now that's terrible that's just a
just a strong attack this is for example
super dangerous and I don't seem like
surviving this difficult to defend the
engine suggests King 2 h8 that's not a
bad idea getting this this out of them
out of this and maybe Ruby aid as a
possibility okay I like this be three
idea
yeah I'm not sure about this and of
course it's still it's a bit it's a bit
crap it's a bit cramped now got this I
still have to be very precise it's not
it's not totally clear the engine some
engine wants to do this interesting move
just looking at age seven and forcing
the matter I mean this is not on and he
gets completely smashed so he has to has
to take and boutiques and this is feels
nice that I could get this Bishop
immaculate say so maybe I can just a 4c
for Bishop see form a 4490 for my engine
gives this verse very strong for the g
file I mean white must be somewhat
better here but it's not not entirely
clear it's not like a simple window a
completely self evident plan that that
is easily found yeah if you are in true
if you want an interesting line against
the charge against the French I'm sorry
this is an interesting way to play an
insert hours with 96 it's a bit more
yeah this is a bit more focused on
gaining space then compared to this line
which is here which is the main line in
on edge f3 or 92 here it's more about
them yeah having fluent piece play and
maybe have the slightly better structure
due to the e5 weakness sometimes these
six is an issue this typical French play
um this is Ella said it's more of a
piece play oriented pro
the other one was just about yeah
grabbing growing big space when I played
in the game okay well thanks for
watching